ah dang it we lost not only did we lose
the DARPA balloon challenge despite
being tantalizingly close to winning
forty thousand dollars to make the
project for awesome that much more
awesome we lost because of the
backstabbing subterfuge of our fellow
nerds the fact that we engaged in
thousands of episodes of backstabbing
subterfuge yesterday does nothing to
make me less angry Hank as the old
saying goes sticks and stones can break
my bones but only nerds can hurt me so
here's what happened thanks to thousands
of nerdfighters including hundreds who
were dispatched to drive around their
cities chasing after false leads we were
on the verge of completing the balloon
challenge when MIT came out of nowhere
in one whereupon we found out that we
actually weren't on the verge of
completing the balloon challenge because
the Nerds at MIT called some nerdy
friends of theirs in Michigan and they
conspired to put up a fake balloon with
a fake DARPA representative for the
express purpose of tricking
nerdfighteria which worked but I still
think we would have won except that MIT
was willing to pay people for
information and we weren't so we lost
because we wouldn't sell our stupid
integrity I think I think there's a word
for people who are willing to sell out
their nerd values in order to get money
what is that word oh yeah sellouts just
kidding MIT team you played a great game
and if we ever do this again we're gonna
punish you and make you cry like you
haven't since you were in third grade
and Jonathan Durkin called you a poopy
pants which by the way you weren't you
might have farted in your pants but you
certainly didn't poop and being a farty
pants is completely socially acceptable
I hope we get to do something like that
again nerdfighteria because it was a
real pleasure to share yesterday with
you I want to thank the thousands of
nerdfighters who gave us tens of
thousands of tips and who diligently
inserted such convincingly false
information that they sometimes tricked
us and I want to thank the Ning masters
over at nerdfighters com who worked
incredibly hard to sort through EADS and
confirm balloons and Hank I want to
particularly thank our secret brother
whose last name comes from a different
color dan Brown
aka youtube.com slash pogobat because
yesterday Dan Brown made about 20,000
phone calls he called the manager of a
trailer park in Biff Florida he called a
Ben & Jerry's in New York State he
called a prison he got all the prison
guard and he was like hey I want you to
look outside the window do you see a red
balloon look to your left and lastly I
want to thank everyone who called six
six zero six nine dftba from the really
helpful calls in Scottsdale Arizona
the number of the balloon was number two
I have a confirmed fitting on balloon
number two one cycle in number one in
Union Square San Francisco balloon
number nine in Portland Oregon to the
insane calls get on one it's in your mom
- Napoleon Dynamite hey I think I can
speak for you and I say that yesterday
was the most fun we've ever had not
winning $40,000 nerdfighters every time
you come together to do something it's
incredibly fun and while we didn't win
the $40,000 we can think of this as a
way of kind of limbering up for the
project for awesome coming to you as it
always does on December 17th oh and if
you don't know what the project for
awesome is look right beneath me not in
my pants
creepers Hank I'll see you on Tuesday
MIT we're not going to tell you the hour
or the day but we're coming for you one
day there will be a decisive contest for
interneural domination and we will be
the mandrill pars Bureau to your T Cobra
hey oh you don't know that reference MIT
maybe you're not so nerdy after all